o qu Eita [__] aqui a pegada é franca
amor de mãe é bem melhor de que eu
conselho
é o qu mentira é
mentira í E aí galera que assiste meu
canal tudo bom com vocês T de dug mas
não para me apropriar culturalmente é
porque eu estou de tran mas não para me
apropriar culturamente de novo é porque
eu vou lutar box aí os lutadores eles
tram as cabe quando são grandes para que
não atrapalhe bolo tá de novo cara dia
14 de outubro provavelmente seja hoje
porque eu tô gravando esse vídeo no dia
13 e o que que acontece falando sério
agora sem não sei que PR lá sem não sei
que para cá direto ao ponto se não usar
a touca de cetim para dormir com a
trança estraga a trança e como não tinha
touca de cetim minha amiga diega botou
esse durag em mim acho que tá acabando a
bateria do bicheiro mudar PR cá Que tal
não moço sim moço quer comprar PR
assistir a luta é o primeiro link da
descrição do vídeo aí vocês já estão aí
oo tu vai lutar de novo cara PR tu
apanhar de novo gente eu também penso
assim mas é que eu acho muito legal as
pessoas britânicas nes a picture please
a picture please não F com a gente aí
nes a pictur please n só britânicos é de
todos os lugares angolanos
indianos os Car ma gente boas cara você
quer que eu não passo por esse momento
da minha vida caramba eu acho Masso esse
negócio de você outra pessoa você marca
Lutar em tal lugar todo mundo assistindo
e outra pessoa paga Olha que sistema
legal e Perdendo ou ganhando o gagal
Olha já entrou no bolso do papai a minha
mãe fica igual a vocês toda luta ela de
ruim diso é a última né Wi aí eu digo é
mãe para que que vou lutar mais aí os
caraba diz tanto milhão aí eu volto PR
ela amor de mãe é muito é
verdadeiro amor de mãe eu sei que é mais
do que um conselho é mãe deixa eu lutar
box de novo vi como é ganhar também eu
não sabia como era ganhar só sabia como
era apanhar agora apanhei de novo né pro
pro Slenderman chamou ele de Slenderman
diab os braços de 2 met Eu quase não
enxergando o homem que eu sou meio Milk
mas assim vendo que ele tava longe as
vorona vupo passava aí perdi né mas como
eu falei o gagau Mas soube como é ganhar
contra o polonês toda hora olhava para
mim niev niev niev niev que é minha [__]
puf vai comendo enquanto arroz seca essa
última eu perdi eu acho que vocês
desacreditaram de mim mas eu aceitei
essa luta porque já tinha vendido muitos
dos ingressos e tudo da galera daqui
então tipo eu tô indo aos lugares aqui
como um lutador normal e as pessoas fic
falando quem é esse cara com esse tanto
de milhão de seguidor E por que que ele
tá lutando box Cara eu acho massa um
cara do Piauí tá indo fazer sucesso fora
do Brasil sem nem saber falar inglês eu
sei um pouquinho de inglês mas eu não
gosto nem de praticar eu acho massa tipo
falar a língua que você nasceu a galera
fala assim PR mim aqui speaks brazilian
quando eu quero falar inglês fala é fala
fala brasileiro se aparece alguma
postagem aí todo mundo é não é
Brasileiro é falar português mas a gente
tem que ser inteligente para entender a
ignorância de algumas pessoa eu perdi na
última luta eu sei que vocês
desacreditaram um pouquinho mas eu
queria que vocês acreditassem e
assistisse essa eu vou lutar contra um
cara muito legal legal que é o my mate
Nate lá da Tailândia eu gostei de tudo
que eu aprendi com Box até aqui eu quero
continuar aprendendo que eu acho legal
quando eu ganhei eu aprendi a ser mais
humilde cara porque eu entendi que o
tamanho daquela Vitória Foi por causa do
cara o cara foi no meu país falar mal o
cara ficou falando que ia me pegar que
ia me quebrar tia do Brasil o segurança
entrada com máscara de Luiz e Vitão cara
eí criou-se Cia aí a gente em Londres
lota um estádio de pessoa gritando Piauí
Piau oon oon e a Galera É obrigada de
novo a se perguntar R that boy é esse
menino eu acho muito legal um negócio
desse tamanho para mim ter essa
importância toda eu ainda consigo ter
muita gratidão ao filipec por esse
momento ter acontecido na derrota pro
King Kenny eu aprendi que é difícil
dizer algumas palavras para quando
alguém fracassa que quando eu ganhei meu
celular não parava de chegar mensagem
galera querendo até ir ver o treino não
foi nem no treino passado querendo
chegar perto e tudo mais quando eu perdi
se eu recebi umas cinco mensagens eu eu
ó logo tu é o important não mas vocês
sabem que tem um um volume maior eu
recebi umas cinco seis mensagens isso
quando eu perdi por qu porque é mais
difícil você tem que pensar muito PR
poder criar frases para uma pessoa que
fracassou dá muito trabalho que que você
faz melhor não falar ah não falei com
você naquele dia porque não sei né como
você porque é difícil é porque mais
fácil falar bicho eu tô contigo desde
sempre [__] que [__] desde que tu
começou a lutar eu assisto todas e tu é
[__] se eu tivesse ganhado 15 seguida
quando
perde Ah acho que é melhor deixar ele
não é porque você não sabe dizer porque
eu consigo dizer coisas para alguém que
não passa num vestibular que não foi bem
no show de música perder um investimento
que tá passando por dificuldade
financeira problema em casa na família
no amor no coração é difícil E aí você
vai ter que falar um coisas Profundas eu
não gosto de falar muito e eu quero ver
o que que essa luta tem para me
proporcionar Eu sinto que eu tô criando
boas memórias assim eu acho muito legal
cara tem hora que eu olho no espelho e
fala mas rapaz onde é rapaz tu bicho tu
é danado mesmo cara tu bicho não se
aquieta não né cara luz apagando e tu au
vamos fazer isso vamos fazer Bicho Vai
te deitar cara rapaz Você você um caba
bicho mas você tá mais bonito tô achando
é aí rapaz você não tá uma Ferrari não
mas você tá um um corol zinho com as
maçanetas todas cromadas hein Mas
voltando no assunto bicho tu se mete
Muita confusão né bicho porque tu não
porque tu não pensa em pintar quadros
que tu quer coisas de sangramentos mas é
assim mesmo né cara tá certo né E tem
mesmo isso P aqui
diga isso não sou eu do outro lado é se
chama reflexo isso aí é uma onda viu
muito legal também sair na mão com regra
é massa parou aí tem que parar porque o
acabo disse para parar o juiz né bom mas
é isso é mais um convite mesmo para você
assistir Minha Luta dia 14 de outubro
primeiro link na descrição do vídeo é o
pay-per-view aqui em Manchester na
Inglaterra também luta no mesmo evento
King Kenny contra outro cara Logan pa de
Lenos k Tommy Fury e eu luto contra o my
mate Nate Espero que você você Assista e
veja o que que tem para oferecer esse
momento Hein eu acho que eu tô criando
boas memórias Eu acho que eu tô criando
boas memórias esquece de clicar em
gostei aí para eu fazer mais eu tô
fazendo mais vídeo direto cara mas vocês
também se você não clicar no Gostei você
me perturba tamos junto é nós precisa
editar que eu preciso dormir porque
amanhã é dia de F primeiro link na
descrição do vídeo tamo junto e é nós
valeu